lucas is on for his 14th start his era
of 381
96 strikeouts and 75 and two-thirds
that's very good his control has been
great only 25 walks as you can see
left-handers have a hard time with them
and there's five in the lineup for the
raids
[Applause]
okay so this is a really good change up
motion wise but it's not anywhere close
to where he wanted to throw it
so eventually that location is going to
come to him right now it's just pure
deception he has la well out ahead of it
and there's another one
[Music]
seeing it for the first time in a couple
years
ain't no fun for anybody no this time
lucas threw it exactly where
zach wanted it i mean it's low and away
it's perfect to a right hander you see
the grip he turns it over a little bit
to get some late movement it also dips
at the end
and rosa rainey has probably seen his
fill of change-ups the last couple of
days aaron for the tampa bay rays this
afternoon it's going to be left-hander
ryan yarbrough making his 10th start of
the season 14th overall appearance the
record at 4-3 era 363.
72 innings 59 strikeouts does a nice job
of limiting walks does a very nice job
of limiting hard contact
a little roller
back to second they're going to get the
out there and a nice play diaz coming in
on that ball yeah well and only because
he's playing that far in because with
tim anderson running you know you've got
to get rid of that ball so quickly but
diaz playing in to take away the bunt
says you know what i got enough time and
what an athletic play nice scoop by joey
wendell yeah the scoresheet sometimes it
doesn't match up with what actually took
place
swing and a miss
so he takes care of vaughn
first strikeout
for yarbrough
[Applause]
and he got him on the pitch away right
there strikes him out
that's what works for gia lato the
fastball changeup combination two old
hit on the ground a second coming in and
making the play as mendic
and that will do it
a quick one two three in the second
oh one count to garcia
on the ground
wendell takes care of that
so a one two three second and we're
headed into the third no score
there it is and it's wrapped to third it
is garcia
in one motion nine up nine down for
lucas giolito
[Applause]
carried away with his
offensive exploits
he's out on strikes this time
better change up this time around
that pitch down is popped up
wendell in short center makes the catch
out from the shortstop spot base hit the
man left
scoreless through three
there's a fastball hit in the air into
right center it's goodwin and lamb and
it is both of them colliding
and it's goodwin eventually
who secures the baseball i believe for
route number one
i thought it was lamb because he might
be a touch taller we'll see this shows
you though the wind is a factor because
this is a routine fly ball that almost
drifted out of the ballpark
no it is
it is good when making the catch after a
bump
you know when you don't play together a
lot
this kind of stuff happens but you can't
afford and look at he's done a nice job
through the lineup staying consistent
and actually improving as far as the
average goes
there's a hot shot fair headed for the
corner and left
ron's gonna have to go get it rosarina
on his way to second will make a turn
and hold with the double
so the rays get their first hit
a double
there goes choi well fortunately
the bet went much farther than the ball
and lucas who found the first two guys
that he looked at finally gets another
strikeout this is a really good pitch i
mean that's the best change up he's
thrown you saw the late movement you see
how he turns it over this one just dives
away
and troy
lets the bat go
[Applause]
struck him
out two to start the game
two to end the fourth now you see it now
you don't
jose has seen a steady diet of off-speed
pitches and everything away let's see if
he learns from that first at-bat
jose cracks his ball to left field it is
out of here
his first hit in the series
and the sox take the lead on this
beautiful afternoon
well apparently jose did learn something
at first at back he took a couple of
pitches
and then took out number 12 with 51
driven in that is a good feeling for
jose they're still playing him in a
severe shift despite the fact that he
went to left field in the third inning
yep left side
that's down
here comes a pair zach collins doubles
your lead
sucks once again playing who wants to be
a hero
it truly is a different guy every day
kevin
the rays want to answer with something
here
that's a fly ball back into center
goodwin's still on the run that's going
to want to hop the wall graves will get
diaz and wendell holm as he scoots
across the plate on the double by
kiermeier and the rays cut the deficit
in half it's four to two
struck him out the disappearing change
up
to god
and a two and one from geo
[Music]
on the ground to third garcia snares it
and abraham picks it four to two the
lead remains
they're going to be charging at the
corners but you want to make sure that
diaz fields this if you do bunt
there it
is has to go to first and it's right in
the bag
sucks will get a run
nobody out
wonky defense from tampa bay
and it's five to two
two one lined in the left fair ball
goodwin will score
bond to second
he's got a double six to two they get
those two runs right back
jake's got himself an rbi
seven to two
against the best team in baseball
so two up two down in the sixth
yandy diaz
that liner into left field that ball's
got a chance and it will get out of here
a line drive yandy diaz home run on a
2-2 pitch
so the reigns pick up their third run of
the day
yandy diaz lining a 2-2 pitch out to
left
nothing has been decided yet raised with
a few innings left here cenino drew a
walk in the fifth
he swings and it's a high fly ball
deep to left and that baby is gone
now swing of the bat from zanino
and the rays cut the deficit
in half that's number 13 for zanino that
four-run deficit turns into a two-run
deficit on one swing of the bat
and a ground ball right side
mounted second over the front it's not
going to be in time the wrong will score
so the rays make it a one-run ball game
this is a resilient team
they play through the end of the game as
hard as anybody 3-2 a game
get on the ground and through into left
center field a base hit with the runner
going phillips is going to round third
and head to the plate he is
safe and this game is tied
phillips
breaking 3-2 scores from first it is 7-7
90 feet separate the socks from a series
win against tampa bay and here comes
rondo yes
right field
and the white
sox have the best record
in major league baseball
walk it off yes
8-7 your final
every day
they find a way